اذا ماذا نعرف عن حركه مواطنين الرايخ هذه
الحركه التي تعرف بانها حركه من اقصى
اليمين المتطرف ومعروفه ايضا بعنصريتها
تجاه الاعراق والمعتقدات الدينيه تتبع
الحركه اذا القوانين التي كانت على ايام
الامبراطوريه الالمانيه وتلك التي وضعها
النازيون قبل اكثر من 70 عاما من هنا ياتي
اسمهم
لوائهم لالامبراطوريه الالمانيه اجهزه
الاستخبارات الالمانيه تصنف الحركه بانها
مصدر تهديدا للمجتمع الديمقراطي الالماني
لانها لا تؤمنوا بالدوله الالمانيه ويرفض
اعضائها الامتثاله للقوانين اتباعها
يتجاهلون تقديم طلب فواتير الضريبه او دفع
الغرامات الحكوميه او الاستجابه للدعوات
الموجهه من قبل المحاكم والسلطات
الالمانيه السلطات الالمانيه بدات بتتبع
المنتمين للحركه بعد واقعه قتل ضابطا من
الشرطه الالمانيه في اكتوبر من 2016 من
طرف شخص ينتمي للحركه وصل عدد واتباع
الحركه بحسب بياناتها هيئات حمايه الدستور
في الولايات الالمانيه الى اكثر من
15000 في عام 2018
خاصه بها